okay guys I am here at the Disney lot
what's the quote it's fun to do the
impossible is that what Walt Disney said
I'm here of doing one of my favorite
characters group I'm working with the
Russo brothers what's up gang it's been
awesome and look at that hand nobody's
seen that hand my kids are gonna be
really jealous we're here and I just
wanted to shout everybody out and and
say happy Women's Day and mom I love you
and we're here and we're creating magic
and it's very very exciting what I'm
seeing is gonna drive you guys crazy I'm
so lucky that I'm able to see it and
have my own little Greek script that no
one else gets to see that I get to hear
all the I get to know the two lines
behind every little thing that I do it's
very exciting to see the evolution we
were talking about this group might be
the only character in recent cinema
where we get to watch his evolution
Oscar that's right I mean you know he is
very different characters you know you
get to see him a lot of different age
range is that a new age range in this
movie you see a different group one that
you haven't one that's going through the
teenage years and we all know what
that's like it's it's just beautiful to
be here like I said we are on the Disney
lot 20 years ago I was here for Iron
Giant and I just came out from New York
it was a New York is a theatre actor and
so excited to be on the lot yeah for the
first time and so I'm always that that
memories always brought back to me guys
we're gonna go back into the ADR booth
we're having a blast when you see
Avengers infinity war you'll know what
we're talking about
it's
citing the rooster brothers are killing
it
you really are really excited about this
and marvel man you guys never let us
down alright get ready gang
hey everybody its Charlie we got some
new infinity war to break down so let's
do it most of you guys probably know
what's going on with that that's just
the Infinity Gauntlet from the Marvel
Legends line there's like six different
versions of the gauntlet that Marvel is
selling this is the same one that Joe
Russo was wearing in that video it's
like they're just wearing them around a
lot like it's no big deal like just
handing him out like they're party
favors this will be need in our NYX
behind-the-scenes promo with them just
walking around nothing about the movie
just then walking around doing normal
tasks while wearing the gauntlet so if
you guys didn't know I am doing a
giveaway for the gauntlet every week all
you have to do to enter that it'd just
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video but the really cool thing that
Vin Diesel talks about during this is
the evolution or the continuing
evolution of Groot which is actually a
hat tip for what's going on in the
infinity war prelude comic book as well
as the future of Groot during the next
two Avengers films so he's adolescent
group right now and probably one of my
favorite trailer shots so far has been
the shot of him Thor in rocket on their
way to the space Forge to talk to the
king of the dwarves you look at Thor you
look at rocket they seem really
concentrated on what they're doing
really serious and you look over at
adolescent Groot and he's just playing
on his phone playing video games still
since the end of guardians of the galaxy
- he couldn't care less about who
they're going to see even if it is the
person who forged Mjolnir so they're
little part of the story is actually
really cool because it's all about
forging Thor's new weapons so there's
obviously a whole bunch of gaps to be
filled there I don't know if we'll get
any footage of that from the trailers
but we do know that Groot donates some
of his wood to create the handle for the
new Stormbreaker axe I did a video a
little while ago talking about James
Gunn clarifying what's going on with
this version of Groot how he's basically
the child of the group that we saw
during the first guardians of the galaxy
film he doesn't have any of his memories
but while that's a big change from the
comic book in the comic book they just
hide roots or
one of the elders of the universe and is
actually a really interesting story beat
that they could pick up on during
guardians three because doing really
weird cosmic stuff is sort of their
purview so if you're gonna do one of the
elders of the universe like Jeff
Goldblum Thor Ragnarok it's better to do
it in a space-based movie and it just
screams guardians of the galaxy
so in this infinity countdown comic the
gardener implies that he created Groot
or at least created his race originally
in the comics Groot was just created to
be part of this race of talking trees
they lived on a different planet they
had their own culture Groot was exiled
because he killed one of his own kind to
protect a human recently though like I
said the gardener implies that he
created Groot like he created their
entire race I don't think he would just
specifically create group because he's
not one of a kind there are other beings
like him but the gardener's big thing is
that he's all about nature think of him
as being like the cosmic version of
poison ivy way back in the comics he
uses one of the infinity gems to grow
massive gardens on a planet-wide scale
they probably do have a plan for
introducing the other elders of the
universe into the movies in a fun way
but like I said mostly cosmic movies
which means that it falls under James
Gunn's purview because he's sort of the
Kevin Feige of their space based movies
he has this wider executive role that he
took on in the last couple of years
where they're planning more cosmic
movies that aren't guardians of the
galaxy so in addition to directing and
riding guardians 3 he's also helping
oversee the development of all these
other big movies he's always talked
about doing a Groot rocket spin-off so
it's always possible that they could use
the gardener as part of that story like
they delve into groots origins you don't
know much about his people even though
you really care about the characters
they haven't bothered to explain much of
his backstory in the last couple of
films so let me know Guardians three
they wrap up this roster of guardians
before they cycle the team a little bit
maybe Adam warlock joins the team by the
end of the movie maybe another different
character from Earth joins the team do
you want to see them do more of a rocket
Groot origin story during that or would
you rather just see them do a spin-off
movie to address that like without
having to provide arcs for a bunch of
different characters just focus on those
two Jeff Goldblum has expressed interest
in doing a movie with Benicio del Toro
as their collector Grand Master
characters I just I gotta say I'm proud
of you all
this revolution has been a huge success
yay us the way that they work together
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe is a
little bit hazy right now we don't know
how close they are in the comics they're
much more of a brotherhood that because
they're so ancient they don't
communicate with each other very often
but usually each elder is aware of what
the others are doing at any given time
even though they live in very different
parts of the universe
what do you let it lick you like that
for growth I know everybody wants to
know when that next trailer is gonna
drop there is a special feature Rhett
that's gonna drop on Monday night I'll
do a video for that but an actual
trailer will be dropping really soon -
Louie Esposito one of the most powerful
producers at Marvel was like just chill
everybody it's right around the corner
meeting like next two weeks so if it
doesn't drop this week it'll drop next
week as I'm posting this video so don't
worry they drop I will totally do a
video for it but leave all your requests
in the comments below and for those of
you asking the gauntlet is as big as it
looks so what will happen is is I'll
name a new giveaway winner when I post a
new marble so that'll be tomorrow night
but click here for that soul gem video
that I just posted and click here for
that big preview thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]